ladies and gentlemen welcome to the uh
tim dillon show from a guest studio some
psychopath in
north carolina get that black owl by the
way i don't know why he doesn't do
research
we walk in the house and some guys like
i interview dead people
and i have a product where i have to
interview people that are right about to
cross over
and this is going on so so uh
you know this this is because he doesn't
do research
we're sitting here in a [ __ ]
someone's lair doing this show i don't
know what this is
but you know
did you get a good feeling from the guy
that uh brought us down here
well his company name is right there i
don't know i mean i couldn't get a worse
feeling from him
i just said he's he goes i know you guys
don't like tech people but i'm one of
the good ones that's what he said that
no one who's one of the good ones ever
says i'm one of the good ones
then he tells us i'm doing a
podcast with people that are dying for
my product
so he wants to suck the last life out of
human beings for his product
and and then um so thanks
thanks for uh researching that
they love life to the tech people they
love death
and they're very fascinated with it
because they they
they want to figure out a way to like
extend life without anything
good in it that's the main goal
is to just push it out as far as it
could go 150 160 years and then
eventually
just forever but a completely
joyless sexless
miserable existence forever for eternity
i don't know why i don't know what
they're
so i know it seems to be utopian for
them like that's their idea of
like a heaven is just straight okay but
that was that what he's doing here in
north carolina
is this where the real tech people come
out of is north kakalaki
that's where the top tier tech people
are in north carolina
ah well i wanted to talk about this case
today
uh i don't really feel like doing the
show today but we're gonna do it
um i feel like uh
when i'm not in the studio it's very
hard for us to be on the road now and
not be in the uh
studio because the you know
we got to be out here doing stand-up and
we're just
borrowing studios from you know assorted
psychopaths
uh that have podcast studios in their
homes which are generally people that
are unwell
uh because they are you know coming down
what did he say recorded 100
episodes so he found 100 dying people he
found a hundred people who were dying
and spoke to them and said would you
like to do a podcast
before the end where does he find 100
dead dying people
i couldn't find a hundred dying people i
know very few dying people
what does he call the hospitals you
think he has a guy in the hospital
on the inside that goes yeah they're
right about to check out
you guys he's in the end stage stage
four
pancreatic cancer uh you want to come
down here
or you want to set up or do they bring i
guess they bring the people in here
so there's been a hundred people brought
down here
brought down here that we're about to
die to the basement and the last thing
they see
is this [ __ ] setup the last thing
they see is a ring light
and a camera and then he said it's for
his product what's his product
i've i'm not sure i'm not quite sure all
these tech companies they're very you
know
you don't really know what they do you
look at you look at their website it
looks nice but you don't really know
what's going on and
yesterday okay well i hope that uh
he's successful and whatever
this this story really got me uh
good here because uh i was a bad
bad driver life is really about a
collection of
uh minutes truly i mean the things that
matter in your life
you know the drudgery of the everyday
like me doing this is like drudgery
um but it's the minutes of it that make
it
uh special or horrible
it's one of the two uh and
these split second things you you wake
up one day you go
i'm gonna do this and then this and then
something happens and your entire life
can be ruined
or it can you know
be saved maybe um
this was a kid and i don't know how the
story stumbled
i i go down to tampa sometimes and i
read the uh
tampa bay times um and
there was an article about this
kid who got into an accident
while racing his buddy
uh he was 18 years old he was in a new
mustang that his parents
bought him uh for
graduation he graduated high school
and he was racing on this thing uh this
road is called bayshore boulevard
in tampa and bayshore boulevard is this
kind of iconic
roadway that's framed with all these
beautiful
stately homes you know they're beautiful
multi-million dollar properties and
his speed limit was about 45 i think
they've moved it down to 35.
i i went with my you know rental car and
i drove around the area where this
accident
was um and this
this guy was doing 102 miles an hour on
that road
racing a friend um
now as he's doing that
a mother a young mother is
crossing the street with a baby
and he sees her
the other car swerves out of the way he
then
stops or tries to stop the car gets
about
30 miles an hour he hits her
and kills her instantly the baby
thrown out of her arms taken to the
hospital dies
the next day um
charged with vehicular manslaughter
and received a sentence of 24 years
rich white good-looking kid is
insanely good-looking um
family was rich lived in a wealthy area
of tampa
they sold their house yeah play one of
his that's the suicide suit they put him
in which is great
they put you in a green anti-suicide
suit
now the other one who's a little bit of
an ugo he got
he got six years and this kid's brother
who was sitting in the car next to him
uh who looks it looks like shrek
got no time at all um
so they a lot of people feel bad for
this kid because he's so good looking
and
a lot of people you know like young
girls on tick tock or like
you know they're they're uploading all
these things you know like videos of him
talk you know i'm in love with the
criminal and
these songs and here's the tick tock
we'll play it
this is what he was doing this guy by
the way is down with the florida state
penitentiary for 24 years
and just because you know he made a
mistake and i'm not saying that
you know he shouldn't be punished he
should be
i mean this is the family happy family
they're all going skydiving they don't
know
that the end is coming look at the one
on the left like shrek
now the end
i mean look at that i mean you're gonna
put him in jail
why is this woman walking her child
in a you like pushing her child
like the idea that first of all the idea
that look at that the idea that she's
the idea that she's blameless here is a
little ridiculous
it's a little ridiculous now i'll be
very honest with you
i understand he should be punished i
understand he did the wrong thing
but this is this this is this dude's
whole
life here you know and
it's a tough call because on one hand
you have this beautiful
promising white rich
guy who's gonna have this great life
and and then on the other hand you have
this
like woman with her
baby who's also a female
and her like fat husband
who's like crying so look at
can we get the fat right here i mean
look at that thing
now it's sad yeah that they're dead
i'm very sad about that
i'm i'm i'm
[Music]
i mean it doesn't seem
fair now google tristan herron because i
i am very much in favor
of putting him in jail because look at
that look at him
imagine having two children and one of
them is that
one of them is this like movie star
and then the other one is that put
him in he belongs in the florida state
penitentiary
look at that goon now
and listen it is just amazing because i
i mean listen
we've all driven drunk we've all done
the wrong thing many of us don't
race our cars that is stupid
but anyone can make a big mistake
and their life can be over
and that's the lesson here but not
anyone can be
that good looking
it's a fact it's a true fact
when good-looking people go out in the
world they inspire other people
that people can fantasize about them
people
can stalk them can want to be them
people can subscribe to the things they
do they're an economy
good looking people can be in economy
and to lock this
this dude away in in a
cell to me seems
not right and people say oh is it
because he's good
yeah yes 100
if it was this i mean can you imagine
i would not even pay it any mind
get what the kid looks like now in jail
oh yeah it's sad
this is a defense of him by the way if
anyone sees this and is
angry let me find that it is there it is
it's rough
now you said they make them shave their
head i would imagine right unless you
already like joined a gang or something
what do you think they do the night
before he turns himself into jail
what is a family the whole family's been
shattered
what do you think they do i don't know
you can't like just go to dave and
buster's and like have a good night
right you got to do something
do you think they [ __ ]
no i'm like dead serious like the night
before
like when you have someone in your home
that looks like that
do you just say hey
like if i was the judge in the case like
i would never be a judge
but i would literally just have to like
i would just have to like
recuse myself because i would give him
like
time served i'd give him no time i'd
give him not a day in jail
but he would have to come like we'd do
community service in my chambers
every week you know
what if the judge gave him a chance like
i'm in the court and i'm like
hello and uh i'm like you can [ __ ] me
or go to jail for 24 years and then he
goes i'll take the jail
and as they're leading him out he goes
end on bi
like just a crazy insult but i mean
what's he doing in jail do you think a
kid like this
he's gonna get bothered right by the
other people
mm-hmm let's not say where he is i don't
want to get we don't i don't know what
the legal
issues are here well that's public
information what where he's in prison
right yeah can we visit him
i believe we could yeah can we like
reach out to him
i think we could figure out how to write
a letter to him but i don't think we can
call him or anything
no face timing no nothing like that we
could write a letter to him
i could be a pen pal to him
what are the chances i could [ __ ] him
like
in jail do you have to be married to
someone to have sex with them
in jail i don't think so no i'm
wondering if i would go to jail
with just the idea that i could be like
a prison relationship
with this dude
i mean i don't know how to react to all
this i'm very sad that the mother and
the baby died
it's horrible i think they should
imprison the brother
and then the other kid but
this guy isn't just good looking i mean
he's insanely good looking that's got to
count
if i were the judge i would say that i'd
be like it's very hard to even
sense you because you're just this
beautiful young man who's gonna have a
great life
and the judge is like i know you'll make
a woman happy i know you'll make her
very happy
and i can picture you making her happy
i'm thinking about you making her happy
i'm thinking about you make yourself
happy on a saturday morning when you're
alone
you probably make yourself happy i'm
thinking of that
i'm thinking of you making a woman happy
i'm thinking of you getting too drunk
and maybe making one of your male
friends happy i'm thinking about
all the things that you're gonna miss
out on and he's gonna come out of prison
gross ugly
bald yeah late 40s holding
with skin issues
there's got to be another way truly
there's got to be another thing to do
with this dude
he only killed two people with a car
literally he killed like two people
there's
gotta be a better way to handle this
situation
you know and i i don't know what it is
but i want we can
can we write him a letter we can write
him a letter we start composing the
letter right now
okay dear cameron
let's write him a letter let's see if
he's
doc here all right dear
dear cameron
your story
moved me
i was a bad driver when i was young
have you ever masturbated while driving
lol you're not spelling it right dummy
i spelled masturbating wrong i think so
maybe not
gonna pop up okay i think there's two
ways to spell it you can do with the u
also have you ever mastered painted
while driving
lol i have
have you ever gotten road head
i would like to suck you in your car
while we drive around killing people
i know you are a good person and you
didn't mean it
what does your [ __ ] taste like
i hope you are finding god
this is very tough to write
can i visit you in prison
let's now read it back to me because i
want to make sure because i want it to
sound good like i don't want it i
obviously want to i
i think it should be like appreciate the
gravity of the situation
but also you want to be sensitive but
right yeah
okay dear cameron your story moved me
i was a bad driver when i was young have
you ever masturbated while driving
lol i have have you ever gotten roadhead
i would like to suck you in your car
while we drive around killing people
i know you are a good person and you
didn't mean it what does your [ __ ]
taste like i hope you are finding god
this is very tough to write can i visit
you in prison
it's not a bad letter
like if because people
need people in jail i've spoke to some
people that have done a hard time
and what they really need is something
kind of like that
motivates them but also gives them
perspective
and i think even though that's short
i think it it jumps around a little bit
and it gives him a few different things
to think about
save that i don't know that we'll send
it we're not going to send it
he's i really do feel bad for the dude i
don't know what to
i don't know what to do it's very sad
right yeah
but if he wasn't good-looking no one
would care i wouldn't care
no one would care but it is crazy when
you think about it
as somebody who is a bad driver like
you know it could have been me it could
have been you it could have been
anybody in 24 years
it's a real moral question you know
should insanely hot people
be subject to the same laws that other
i don't care if this kid killed my
mother
i would not want him in jail truly
i'm not even if he killed my mother
my father my stepmother my aunts
uncles if he i'm telling you right now
if this guy killed my entire family
and most of my friends except ben
because i we got to do this
but if he killed everyone i knew i would
i would still get on my knees
for him immediately and say and say
you know hey you you are
someone is that good looking they they
should
it is kind of a superpower you know
if the rich and famous don't go to
prison why should the hot
that's a good question no one's even
famous anymore really
i mean look at that face he makes with
the big eyes when he learns he's getting
24 years
it's brutal to watch
it's brutal he learns he's getting 24
years
that's tough ladies and gentlemen liquid
iv i can't say enough about it first
thing in the morning before workout when
you feel run down
daily hydration maintenance hangover
cure i love it
uh it's good for me it keeps me uh
energetic to do shows
they have great tasting functional
products they make you feel great they
have a give back mission
they've donated over 11 million sticks
to people around the world
does that mean they'll have a million
dollars or sticks of liquid iv
i think sticks of the the packet great
liquid iv hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone
contains five essential vitamins it's
made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan
free of gluten dairy and soy what makes
liquid iv so effective
cellular transport technology the
optimal ratio of glucose sodium
potassium
delivers water and nutrients into the
bloodstream it's the perfect balance
to help you hygiene more quickly and
effectively than water alone this is
what i'm using
and i love it i love it it gives me
energy to go on stage and all the stuff
i do
uh the company's donating more than four
million servings in response to coven
how great is that it's great grab your
liquid iv in bulk nationwide to costco
or you can get 25
off if you go to liquidive.com and use
code tim and check out crabby liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com use
code tim
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today
using promo code tim liquid iv.com
bluechu you know what bluetooth is about
it's a summer love you got to keep it
keep it uh hard bluetooth.com
promo code td you get the dick pills
process is simple sign up consult one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part it's all done online
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
are prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discrete
package with bluetooth men everywhere
excited
to see the posts man
that you can try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code td at checkout just
pay five dollar shipping
that's b l u c h ew chew dot com promo
code td to receive your first month
free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we
thank bluechu for supporting the podcast
you gotta get it
they've got the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets at a fraction of
the cost
you could take them any time day or
night in the morning
in the afternoon with or without food
they're made in the usa prepared and
shipped direct to your door in a
discreet package
not a package that says dick pills for
the little dick
it's discreet they didn't put
little dick on the package they just
said discrete
it you don't know what it is it's great
bluechew.com
promo code td we're here in north
carolina uh
which is a whatever stain
and uh it's fine
and the duke uh hat i'm wearing
is because one of the one of the reasons
i i came out of the closet excited came
out of 25 i
never would have um um
and many gay people wish i didn't but
uh uh the the head of the duke college
republicans was
impeached which i thought was like the
hottest thing to be a closeted
college republican like i've since
talked to the kid it's not
it's very he's like an annoying kid they
all are anyone involved in like politics
on like a collegiate level or high
school i mean they're all insufferable
you know kids in politics or it's the
worst
and uh i
i had like wrote him an email like a
nice email
not like the one i was going to send a
cameron i mean this was like a nice one
and he sent me back one or whatever i
was okay i think that you're
brave and for what you're doing or
whatever and some other kid was
defending him who later was found out
was like a pedophile
some kid was like some other kid at duke
legit was like
you're not gonna like one of the other
ones this is all true
you can look it up and google it but
i i don't want to start using people's
names i don't know how the but but you
can google this
his like biggest defender was like a
pedophile like
one of the other college republicans was
like
this guy it's wrong to
[ __ ] and then he was [ __ ] kids so
or not but looking at them whatever i
don't know and uh
this guy's like a lawyer now and he's
like fat so i don't have any interest
but i did email him every now and then
i'll email him let's [ __ ]
because he has a a law firm
in philadelphia where he does
anti-discrimination law
just whatever some like useless gay
person gets fired
they call this [ __ ] and then he just
like goes to court and he's like
you're [ __ ] you threw out tammy
because she's a big born dyke and it's
like no
she like got drunk and showed up three
hours late and then like
fought someone and he's like it's you
know so he's just doing like
discrimination
law can we are we legally allowed to
look at his like
he has like an lgbtq law scam
uh yeah i guess if you if you
are like non-binary and are a horrible
employee
and get fired you call this guy and he
like
shows up and he'll convince you that
you're
you're getting fired because you're gay
he'll be like are you gay
you'll be like yeah but i was like i
stole from the company he's like but
you're gay
and there's no place for you in the
straight world
so that's why they fired you and you're
like well i don't know about that
i gotta be honest i mean i was
embezzling money
yep for your transition because they
wouldn't pay for it right
i guess so he's just like a
a con art it's a con it's a scam
um
and um i would email him every now and
then let's [ __ ] but he doesn't email me
back anymore
he used to email me back but now he
doesn't email me back
um can we we can't look at his website
well he's well one he's a lawyer right
so what
he's a he's not a good lawyer he's
defending
like gay people who get like fired from
wendy's
and he's not a good lawyer if you want
to go through though it's like someone
who's like
yo [ __ ] i talked i
told you we ain't got no frosties and
then like they get fired
and then he like shows up and he's like
the injustice
done here today he thinks he's like
martin luther king
he's like the injustice
you know what's your name shadow
when shadow got a job here
at this [ __ ] you know checkers
shadow was an openly gay man and that
made
everybody uncomfortable
and then like the pr the other person
has to get up and go shadow was fired
for selling mass
in the parking lot of checkers he was
actually warned multiple times
to not sell meth and did it anyway
it's because he's a gay man
i'm sure there are instances of people
that are fired because they're
yeah so this is like
this is his yep yep here we go that's
him
two months ago this is a review this is
a review of this kid's law practice
should have [ __ ] me this is a review
very unprofessional in the way that he
communicates you're telling me
and lacked thereof he would schedule
called me never call
and i would reach out and he would act
like it was bothering him i found him to
be very rude in his communication
he would get an attitude when i'd reach
out to him he was scheduled to appeal at
an unemployment hearing via phone
for my case it never showed up
when i questioned it his response was he
wasn't planning on attending he sent the
letter stating
he would attend to be nice and told me
no good deed goes unpunished
would definitely not recommend let's see
some other reviews
this one's not good either very rude and
standoff personality
i agree does not like you to contact him
unless he contacts you
i had to email him three times in week
to receive callback
who fires him by the way he needs to be
fired
and when he called he was angered
because he said him calling me was
taking time out of his day mind you
i haven't spoken to him for three months
i decided to go with another attorney no
longer needed services
huh one guy just writes worked on
my case till the end thank you those are
the are those there
no he's got more let's see what he's got
here
another one star i sought help from this
individual he's very dismissive before i
presented my issue to him
and i did not appreciate the level of
unprofessionalism that was accompanied
when i reached out to him i will not be
utilizing exactly
he's a horrible lawyer and then that's
that one's the pedophile
escaping five stars i swear to god
that's the dude who was like guys
so put him in jail
here's my point i sent him like a lovely
email early on i was like hey
you know i think what you're doing is
great and you're standing up for who you
are and then he spun off into this like
he's like the worst attorney ever
apparently
he like riles up these gay people to
believe that they've been fired
and maybe some of them have for for
discrimination
and then when they call him he like
doesn't answer his phone
because he's like out like doing molly
or something
he's like all coked out and they call
him and they're like he's like i don't
know
he's like he's like who is this
girl you better find a lawyer
um but
i wish him well
he was really good-looking uh can we can
we google image are we allowed to do
that yeah
yeah so back in the day he was very
good-looking but then it kind of you
know
i don't know he might be good-looking
again this was that picture
yeah that was that's that's good looking
the node's a little big
but that's when he was good-looking and
then
then yeah no that's that's a different
person oh okay
but then he got like find his website
let can we we should call as
you should call him and say you're fired
because you're gay okay
find his number call him right now
why not because we're recording without
his consent just tell him you're
fired because you're gay he can't sue us
he won't even show up
this looks like his he's a contributor
to this website this must be it
i i don't know doesn't he have a website
this looks like it's it
that's not his website
just write lawyer lawyer
there's a couple different lawyers with
his name is the problem he's not like
he's the biggest
that's what yeah there he is there he is
yeah right there okay call him call him
from your phone
call him right now and tell him that
you're fired because you're gay
let me find his phone number
say i was fired because i'm gay
oh his license isn't active call him
anyway
no phone number here yeah there was a
phone number
if you go back up go back up yeah
yeah he litigates claims of employment
discrimination
including ones he makes up
he literally he would tell me he'd go
yeah not every one of them gets fired
for being gay but you know who knows
we don't know why they were fired we
just uh you know
we just say it's because the ceo you
know the boss hates gay people
okay i'm gonna call this right here yeah
call that
call that you go i was fired from sonic
because i'm gay
tell them let me connect this
tell him i was fired from sonic because
i'm gay my friend i met a friend uh
my drag queen friend said you helped me
okay i have to let him know i'm
recording
let's say hello first
and then what's my story you're five
from welcome to verizon wireless
the number you dialed has been changed
disconnected or is no longer
dude he doesn't have a business anymore
dude i think he might just be smoking
krill
let me see if i still have him i may
still have him
i don't think so okay i was fired from
sonic for being gay
yeah hi justin
he may know who you are oh really i
don't know
are you gonna hop in at any moment
your call has been forwarded to an
automatic voice message system
yeah just leave a message
is not available at this time at the
tone please record your message
when you have finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
hi justin you don't know me i got your
phone number from a friend
i was fired from sonic because i came
out to my co-workers and my manager
thought that was disgusting and he's
like bigoted
so he basically threw me in the streets
and now i don't have a job and i really
need
a good attorney to represent me here um
um stop um
stop stop so um anyway
uh if you could get back to me just put
it and um
i've just been discriminated against and
uh anyway
oh my god you're so tired thank you so
much
it's not it's not stupid it's his job
it's his fake job so he can now do it
and call you back because you were fired
from sonic yeah it's your [ __ ] job
i'll tell you right now i when i got my
car i was like am i paying too much for
auto insurance and they were like well
why don't you find out i'm like but it's
cost so much they're like no it doesn't
use gabby i was like are you serious
g-a-b-i gabby.com
allows you to quote
real-time quotes you put in your
information and they match the exact car
insurance coverage you have now
to what you have in the market and guess
what if you're paying the best rate who
cares
but on average your customers save 961
dollars a year
isn't that worth it i think it's worth
it
most people they're leaving money on the
table because they don't
get it but i get it so i go to gabby.com
and it the 40 of the top providers
40 quotes immediately
snap of a finger just like that boom
there's the quote
okay put your policy to the test like i
did
get better insurance with gabby it's
totally free to check
and they're hey don't you think there'd
be an obligation
you'd think so i mean this is a saves
you a ton of money
do you know
that there's no obligation oh really
do you know that
oh it's totally free do you know
that there's no obligation i know now
that's a that's wild is it wild
yeah a free service that can save you
this much money
i feel like you're being patronized
gabby.com slash tim dillon
g-a-b-i gabby expressvpn
is is smart every time you connect to an
encrypted network
cafes hotels airports any hacker the
government whoever they're all stealing
your personal data
it doesn't take a lot of technical
knowledge to hack someone just some
cheap hardware
a smart 12 year old could do it and your
data is valuable hackers make up to a g
per person selling personal info on the
dark web man no one i know is worth the
g
but anyway expressvpn acts as your
online insurance
it creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
so hackers can't steal your personal
data it'll take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years
to get past expressvpn's encryption an
expressvpn is simple to use on all your
devices
just fire up the app and click one
button and get protected
we all do it everyone we know has it
this signal things like this technology
is starting to enable you to fight back
against
technology i'll tell you right now
if you go to expressvpn.com tim dillon
that's expressvpn.com
t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n expressvpn.com
tim dillon you are in the best position
you're safe
and secure you get three months free
what the f
three months yeah they're giving away
the store
i can't believe they're doing this they
must know how important safety and
security is
you know what pissed me off too speaking
of gay topics this kid that pretended to
come out this
olivia rodrigo's ex-boyfriend what's his
name
this guy you said harry styles was good
looking and then they're like are you
gay and he's like he's like he's like no
i'm not and then he realized that wasn't
the move
so then he comes out and he goes i don't
know i'm still i don't want to put a box
and
and the gay press is full of a bunch of
idiots and they're all like good for you
i forget his name joshua bassett yeah by
the way
he shares powerful uh message about
sexuality it's okay to still be figuring
out who you are no it's not
how old is he no it isn't how old is he
let's see
what are you going to figure out josh
you're an adult
you should know you want to [ __ ] you
want to [ __ ] women he's 20.
yeah you're not really figuring much out
at 20 anymore
you know you're not gay you're lying and
you're
you immediately he first came out and he
went
find his first statement his first
statement he he just says
harry styles is hot and then he said
something like i guess this is my coming
out video
clearly is a joke he does it clearly as
a joke
the media of course hops on it and goes
well
okay so it's probably on youtube is
where you put it i don't know but the
media hops on it and goes look at joshua
bassett
coming out as queer and then he goes no
no
i was uh that's not me yeah watch this
watch him address his sexual i mean it's
like
what what are we talking about by the
way
let's can we watch this yeah we can
watch this brain dead
these are three brain dead people by
school musical imagine these people
having jobs
the musical star josh bassett got a lot
of attention a couple of days ago with
his comments about harry
styles as he answered fan questions for
clever news take a look at this
what i learned about harry styles is
he's a very classy man
and he's also very well-rounded and you
know he kind of does it all like acting
singing
fashion and i think that he's just a
nice guy who
doesn't say too much but when he talks
like it matters in any sense
he's just cool like he's cool who
doesn't think hairstyles is
also he's hot you know he's very
charming too
lots of things i guess this is my um
this is also my coming out video i guess
uh
okay so people assume this is the 20
year old coming out as gay
when i watched that clip i was like hold
on people i'm not sure that's what he's
doing here
yeah the media outlet gay times posted
an article around it
uh the popular twitter account pop crave
said this is him coming out of the
closet
but joshua didn't say anything right
away at first
hmm yeah but then he did post this
message on instagram yesterday he says
this my entire life people have told me
my sexuality people shame me for things
they know
nothing about what i want to say thank
you to those of you who stand for love
and acceptance
hatred and negativity say less about the
subject
i know it's our 2021 we are a generation
of love and growth what does that
mean you're not the generation of love
and growth
i love you all the same love you love
love who you love shamelessly it's okay
to still be
figuring out who you are life's too
short to listen to ignorance
when i choose love so along with that
message she posted this song
i'm breaking the spell
but this is where like he's dating a
woman he
dates women but he still gets that like
the gay community constantly falls for
this [ __ ]
like nick jonas did it all the time like
he he shakes his dick and everyone's
like
you're are you gay i think he's gay it's
like they're not
they're taking advantage of you okay
it's like what elvis did to the blacks
it's like nick jonas dressed as like a
70s [ __ ]
leather daddy and jumps around and the
gay community's like oh my god
he's [ __ ] a woman and taking your
money
dummy and then this guy's gonna do it
this guy should have to have sex with a
guy on camera
he should have to have sex with the guy
that killed that mother and her child
[Laughter]
where's the lawyer to represent this
where's our lawyer he's not calling back
huh
no apparently he's not that good at his
job i'll try
texting him maybe text him this is
scooter
my name is scooter i was fired from
sonic
because i'm gay
that's all you have to say my name is
scooter
i was fired from sonic because i'm gay
call me back and let's make them pay
dollar dollar dollar sign and then a
wink
[Music]
this guy's barely a real lawyer no it's
all fake
he can't get anything [ __ ] done
get him out of here
go to drudge for a second i wanted to
pull up one thing before we
get out of here we'll be back in the
studio eventually it's
you know being on the road here is uh oh
the president of haiti
is uh we got him or someone got him not
us but someone we
17 people have been arrested he was a uh
he was like a puppet of ours so i think
he was
safe um but
oh yeah this is great fort lauderdale
airport terminals evacuated a mid-bomb
threat
passengers deplaned uh
people on flights now are just beating
each other up
people calling in bomb threats to the
airlines yeah flights are being delayed
they stopped serving alcohol on a lot of
airways stop serving alcohol on a lot of
flights
um you still have to wear the mask
travel is still as miserable as it's
ever been
lauderdale hollywood international
airport uh
investigates security-related incidents
the media has nothing to talk about now
they're just calling in bomb threats to
airports
you're like well yeah covid we're trying
to do that delta thing it's not working
uh
you know we can't get people riled up
about trump so
why don't you call in a bomb threat to
the airport
how about you just call in a bomb threat
to the airport and then we'll figure
that out
we're gonna get out of here folks
patreon.com tim dillon show
um uh you know we are uh in new york
caroline's is all sold out there are
tickets left for the wilbur theater in
boston and foxwoods in connecticut
we're out on the road so some of these
studios were going to be
uh makeshift like the one here in the
home of uh
this character um and i wish him well
with all of his things
what he's whatever he's doing with
people that are about to die
it's always nice why can't you meet one
tech person who
whose description of what they do isn't
completely
haunting like completely haunting he
goes yeah we just
you know we we deal with people who are
right about to die
oh lovely thank you
thanks for that um
but the wilbur theater in boston we've
added shows we've added tickets
uh foxwoods there are some tickets as
well
irvine california at the end of the
month grand rapids michigan i'm in a
theater there
royal oak michigan theater there august
san diego california
i'm there las vegas is a music festival
if you want to go to that i'm performing
to um chicago
from the 24th through the 28th i'm at
the schomburg
improv and it's in the burbs but it's
it's more it's the capacity is bigger so
we got to go
to where the people can come to
schaumburg improv get tickets for that
in chicago
uh at the end of august let's close down
uh
this summer together it'll be a lot of
fun
hopefully we don't get sued by that guy
but it's the reality
this is what he this is what he's about
he could have showed up
[ __ ] me we could have been done i
would have never had a bad word to say
about him and i still don't have
anything bad to say about him i respect
fake business
i respect everything he does and god
bless him
i have no issue with him we're heading
to long island tomorrow the great long
island which ben has
come to love and appreciate what what do
you like about it uh the most
the ignorance the racism probably the
racism yeah
it's an insanely racist place it's so
racist
yeah the food is very good
sloth-like people it's very interesting
when people are
they're like big and move slow but they
have an anger to them
that's long island like they're big and
sloth-like and move slow
but there's an anger to them it's like
the uh what do they call them in star
wars the big uh the things that the sand
people wrote oh the uh
not the uh you know yeah yes yes yes
it's kind of like long island it's
tantans there's just
like an anger uh but we'll be going
there
and we'll be doing shows at uh
caroline's which i'm very excited about
and then we'll be back in the studio
really cool new stuff go listen to that
glenn greenwald episode if you haven't
it is a uh
really amazing look at
the last year uh from somebody who's
looked at it very closely the last
last few years but specifically the last
year we talked a little bit about
january
6th and we talk about
um what's going on out there
um but we've got some cool new videos
coming out uh
the live shows have been really fun it's
been great to have everybody out there
uh supporting us go check out that
episode i did on rogan
uh ray kump is coming up soon we're
going to new york we're going to see him
he'll be on the patreon as well um and
i'm a little scared of being here in
this house like that
i can't believe you didn't even well
this was actually our best option if you
could believe it so
yeah i mean did you do any research at
all
the other emails were like hey i have a
a basement
yeah and like that was it that's not
good
that would you just said i have a
basement yeah yeah so this is
like the only people that have podcast
studios are tech people and then like
open
who do it like twice a year right and
the tech people want to do it
because they they like think they need
to be heard
yeah okay and maybe they do
maybe they do but i wish i wish everyone
the best here what i like is i'm looking
at just a
an open vent
you know that's comforting huh
we're in the middle of the woods we
drove like through the woods to get here
down like a long road yeah
i just hope they kill you too i hope
they don't let you live
what a waste to let you live
and golf i just hope if it comes down to
it
i hope it's both of us that get it
and then i hope that [ __ ] fraud
lawyer gets it too
i hope they kill him
i'm kidding but i do hope they let
cameron out of prison
you know it's a few minutes of life
and you know i was joking
about him you know i'm obviously we're
not sending him
letters but you know he is someone who
i mean it's just [ __ ] with your head
that your life can be altered that
quickly
irreversibly you know
your entire life shattered your family's
life shattered and yes the mother
and her child they're unfortunately dead
and people want vengeance and i
understand that
they want someone to be punished you
know
but there is
you know a certain consideration there
are so
few people that are truly really
beautiful people
and many of them are demons from hell
but we tolerate that
we tolerate that because they are good
looking and i
in this case you know
the judge sent him up the river
24 years
i would have said one month
at my school my driving school
you know it's sad it's very very
uh tough because on one hand two people
are dead
including a baby but on the other hand
i mean this guy you know he's
almost a perfect person with the brown
hair and the curly hair
and the eyes the blue eyes put his
brother and
kill his brother they should be able to
make deals like that in court
they should be able to be like we'll
shoot our other son in the head
right now this big ape will shoot him in
the head
don't take this gorgeous one this shrek
we will shoot him in the head
we will cap him we'll let
the guy do it we'll let the
husband of this this poor woman who died
we'll let him
shoot our sun in the head
but we want to keep the hot one you
don't want to introduce that lug
you want to say here's our hot sun
you know you don't want to be like uh
our hot sun's in jail but now they can
never go out again
you know i mean it just ruins everyone's
life
don't drive fast slow down
it's not worth it
unless you're gay and you can get away
if you kill someone maybe
my that lawyer will take a case
the judge would be like well you did
kill that mother and her baby but you
are gay
and i understand that you've been
through some tough things
yes judge
you know i'm sorry i don't know why i'm
being a k black admit
he's like you know i'm thar and the
judge is like i understand that
and the judge goes all right i'm gonna
sentence you to two weeks
in jail for the death because you're gay
of the mother and the daughter judge i'm
also trans
you will have no time in fact
we will be putting in the husband of her
he will go to jail
and serve it for you
um tim dilloncomedy.com
if you want tickets to any shows we
really got to get out of this [ __ ]
we really got to get out of this [ __ ]
thing i'm kind of scared being here
like i don't have a good feeling about
it do you have a good feeling about it
um i have a bad feeling about when he
listens to this since
my contact what's he gonna do i'd
probably be upset
why because he he led us into his home
loaned us his space and then you just
like ripped him to shreds
but but that's the show
but i'm you know he should have known
better i didn't say anything negative
no not about his character or anything
like that i don't think
just just get it can we get out of here
please quietly
just pack everything up let's go let's
do ads and then
and then we'll oh the [ __ ] hand can
we just do ends now
yes ready yeah okay let me download them
that's the episode folks